at the start of Game of Thrones we meet
the stark family
there's Ned Catelyn Robb and they all
die but we've still got Sansa Arya Brant
reckons alive in the books and there's
John who's secretly half Targaryen at
least in the show we tend to see the
Starks as the good guys but the stark
family aren't the Brady Bunch
in Chapter one Ned the heads a guy and
makes his sons watch and the kids all
get pets from a giant dead wolf it's
clear from the start that the Starks are
connected to harsh ancient customs and
mysterious magic bran becomes a psychic
tree God ayuh a faceless assassin and
John an undead prophetic warrior King
the blood of House Stark is tied to the
ancient secrets of Winterfell and the
wall the night's king and White Walkers
which might hint at the ending of Game
of Thrones
according to legend House Stark began
8,000 years ago after the long night
when the White Walkers came for the
first time the walkers were defeated by
the last hero with the children of the
forest all by azor Ahai with a flaming
sword there are lots of different
legends but the Walkers went away and
Brandon the Builder raised to the wall
to keep them out Brandon also built the
castle of Winterfell and started House
Stark who ruled as kings of winter for
thousands of years eventually a people
called the Andals invaded Westeros from
across the sea bringing a new religion
and culture only the kings of winter
could resist them and that's why the
North keeps the customs of the first men
worshiping the old gods and remembering
things that others forget it all ties
back to the foundation of House Stark in
the fight against White Walkers and
winter the ancient words of House Stark
are a warning that winter is coming
the castle of Winterfell might be named
for the place where the White Walkers
were defeated where Winterfell
Winterfell is built on hot springs that
keep it warm through winter and the
crown of the stark kings was spiked with
iron metal of winter to fight against
the
in the Winterfell crypts the statues of
dead Starks have swords of iron and it
said that White Walkers hate iron
Winterfell might have magic defenses
against White Walkers because the wall
and storm's end have protective spells
and Brandon the Builder is supposed to
have built them both maybe he gave
Winterfell protective spells as well it
said there must always be a stark in
Winterfell as though the Starks have an
ancient responsibility to defend the
north from winter and White Walkers but
the story goes deeper than that along
the wall are 19 castles mostly abandoned
now the oldest is the Nightfort a dark
and sinister place that's connected to
the White Walkers there are stories of a
thing that came in the night that killed
people then brought them back as
shambling slaves like whites there's a
tale of a knight with eyes like blue
stars like a white Walker and the oldest
Nightfort legend tells of the Knights
King in the TV show the leader of the
White Walkers is called the night king
but he seems to be a different character
to this night's King because the night's
king was Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch and he met a woman with skin cold
as ice and eyes like blue stars which
sounds like she was a white Walker the
night's king made her his queen and gave
her his seed and his soul together they
ruled the Nightfort and made sacrifices
to the White Walkers which might mean
that they gave their children to the
walkers like how the wildling Craster
sacrifices his children the night's king
and queen ruled for 13 years until they
were cast down by the stark King Brandon
the breaker old records of the night's
king were destroyed and his name was
forbidden wiped from the memory of man
why was the name of the night's king so
important
well old nan says the night's king who
was the brother of Brandon the breaker
that the night's king was a stark so did
an ancient stock marry a white Walker we
can't totally trust these old legends No
really knows what happened thousands of
years ago but the stories are there to
give us hints and there was obviously
some kind of white walk action at the
Nightfort which might have been part of
the plan from the beginning because in
book three we see the Black Gate a
secret hidden magic gate at the
Nightfort
that lets Watchmen through the wall it's
made of a living weirwood face at the
bottom of a deep dark well it's super
creepy and looks like just the sort of
gate you'd use if you were secretly
given babies to white walkers and thing
is the Black Gate is as old as the wall
itself it was built into the Nightfort
from the start was this place designed
for sacrifice to the white walkers the
Nightfort was the Chiefs seat of the
Nights Watch for thousands of years it
was the first castle on the wall
possibly built by Brandon the Builder
founder of House Stark so why do its
oldest legends point to sacrifice and
marriage to White Walkers one popular
theory is that the walkers weren't just
defeated in the long night that there
was actually a peace agreement we know
that lots of wars in the north ended
with the Starks marrying a daughter of
their enemy so maybe the long night
ended with the stark Knights King
marrying a white Walker
we know that Craster makes peace with
the walkers by sacrificing his children
so maybe sacrifice at the Nightfort was
part of this white Walker peace deal we
also know that humans once made a pact
with the children of the forest and this
was done before a grove of weirwood
trees maybe the weirwood Black Gate
represents a similar pact between the
white walkers and the Starks maybe a
marriage alliance with the white walkers
is how the Starks became kings of winter
and built the icy wall maybe the phrase
there must always be a stark in
Winterfell was part of this ancient
agreement this is just speculation if
there ever was a peace with the walkers
it's now forgotten but the Starks might
still be connected to the walkers by
their blood as a theory that the Starks
are descended from the night's king and
his icy Knights Queen
a game of Thrones is full of symbolic
repetitions and parallels it's like
poetry at rhymes and one of the stories
that's repeated is of a baby boy with a
secret special bloodline being raised as
a stark at Winterfell
for example Jon Snow is secretly the son
of Rhaegar Targaryen but John is raised
as Ned Stark's son at Winterfell another
example is the story of Bale the bard
where the son of a wildling was raised
as a stark at Winterfell and there's a
similar story with gillies baby
remember that Gilly is one of the wives
of Craster who gives his songs to the
White Walkers
when Gilly gives birth to a son she and
Sam run south to save the baby
passing through the Black Gate the
Nightfort the plan is to raise Gilley's
baby as Sam's bastard and John considers
raising the boy at Winterfell so over
and over there's a story of a baby boy
with a secret bloodline being raised at
Winterfell maybe the same thing happened
with a child of the night's king like
we're told that Brandon the breaker cast
down his brother the night's king what
if Brandon found one of the Nights kings
children had the Nightfort would Brandon
murder his own baby nephew when kin
slang is such a crime in the north or
would Brandon take his brother's baby to
Winterfell and raise him as his own just
like Ned raised John and the Starks
raised bales son the story of bale
reveals that the Starks have wildling
blood maybe the story of the night's
king reveals that the Starks have the
blood of the Nights Queen the blood of
White Walkers we are told that the
Starks are not like other men that
they're made of ice and made for the
cold old stark kings included Brandon
ice ice and edrick snow beard they named
their sword ice just like the White
Walkers use swords of ice maybe to the
ancient kings of winter the words winter
is coming was a boast and a threat
because the ancient Starks didn't
accidentally take over the north they
conquered kingdom by Kingdom
slaughtering men stealing wives wiping
out entire
houses these stocks were bad guys who
did terrible things maybe in this brutal
past the Starks embraced their white
Walker blood just as the targaryen
embraced their blood of the Dragon in
their conquests there's a great symmetry
in the Targaryen 's having fiery dragon
blood if the Starks have icy white
Walker blood but being related to ice
demons must have gone out of fashion
because now the stock seemed to want to
deny their white Walker heritage like
that'd be why they hide the stock name
of the night's king and these iron
swords in the crypts were told that they
keep the spirits of the Dead locked in
their tombs why do the Starks need to
lock away their own ancestors maybe
because their ancestors are part white
Walker
maybe the Starks started using these
iron swords to lock away their icy
heritage maybe the iron in the crown of
the kings of winter is there to suppress
the white Walker in the mind of âge
stark may be winter film isn't built
just to keep Walker's out it's built to
keep White Walkers in this whole thing
could be very Lovecraftian HP Lovecraft
was a horror writer who influenced Game
of Thrones author George Martin
there are Lovecraft references all over
the world of Thrones go watch our east
video and one of Lovecraft's recurring
ideas is the fear of something terrible
in your ancestry
in one story called the shadow of
Innsmouth the narrator finds out that
he's descended from evil fish gods
called Deep Ones he tries to resist the
deep ones but ends up joining them in
the sea maybe
similarly the Starks will discover to
their horror that they're descended from
White Walkers but we'll have no choice
but to join them remember that Gilley's
baby who was meant to be sacrificed to
the White Walkers apparently to be
transformed into one so when Gilly and
Sam take the baby south instead the
White Walkers come after them to take
back the baby that was promised maybe
that's what's happening with the Starks
like if the Starks are all descended
from a baby of the night's king who is
meant to be sacrificed
maybe the walkers are now
coming south to take back what's owed to
take the Starks as their own
John snow is set up as the guy to bait
the White Walkers but surely the story
won't end with just like a sword fight
with the night king author George Martin
says that Game of Thrones isn't about
good guys fighting bad guys
it's about conflicts within the human
heart like love versus duty survival
versus sacrifice and that's what Jon's
story is all about he sacrifices his
honor his love his own life maybe now
he'll have to sacrifice himself to the
White Walkers he is the prince that was
promised in more ways than one
maybe he'll represent the stark blood
promised to the White Walkers Jon makes
peace with the wildlings maybe he'll
make peace with the White Walkers it
could be another marriage pact Jon could
become the new night's king there are
lines in the books about Jon having
armor made of ice and his skin growing
pale and cold the tragedy here would be
that Jon has just fallen in love with
Daenerys so again he'll have to choose
between love and duty between fire and
ice between banging his aunt and
becoming a popsicle King to save the
world
it's fantasy and it's human drama and
it's bittersweet this could be the end
of Game of Thrones if you liked this
video please like and subscribe we'll be
making lots more videos for the final
season of Game of Thrones for more on
the Starks and White Walkers check out
Lucifer means light bringer ideas of Ice
and Fire
gray area and others the community's
done lots of great analysis on this
stuff thanks to artists Orianna Weisner
clara docks pop Ozzy and attached altar
nose this video topic was chosen by the
patrons at patreon.com slash old shift X
the thanks to patrons dr. Biggio vidura
Jackie afon Travis Layla William
Applegate story hideous myth Majora's
Mask Jordan Belle max Campania Casper
Sedgwick Sam ghosts and soul Vohland
Cheers